Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support case file on your preferred platform.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。本集最初发布在 CaseFiles 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上，作为我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集并享受无广告体验，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。
Please note that this episode discusses the subject of suicide and won't be suitable for all listeners. If you need support, please visit lifeline.org.org.aU. For listeners outside of a you can find a list of mental health resources on the crisis links page of our website. During the summer of 2006, English grandmother Celia Bley found herself spending more and more time on the internet. At almost 60 years of age, Celia was a retired teacher and a self-professed technophobe with minimal computer experience. But after both of her elderly parents died in quick succession, Celia found that being online was a good distraction from her grief. Although Celia kept horses and had a small business making whips for carriages, these hobbies
请注意，本集讨论了自杀话题，可能并不适合所有听众。如果您需要支持，请访问 lifeline.org.au。对于澳大利亚以外的听众，您可以在我们网站的危机链接页面上找到心理健康资源列表。2006 年夏天，英国祖母西莉亚·布雷发现自己花在互联网上的时间越来越多。西莉亚快 60 岁了，是一位退休教师，自称是几乎没有电脑经验的“技术恐惧者”。但在她年迈的父母相继去世后，西莉亚发现上网是缓解悲伤的好方法。虽然西莉亚养马，还有一家制作马车鞭子的小生意，但这些爱好
weren't enough to fill up her days. Celia liked to browse newsgroups within the Usenet system. News groups operated the same way as message forums, with separate groups dedicated to all kinds of subjects such as pop culture, music, travel and many others. Celia mostly stuck to the history news group and she had a particular interest in medieval history. As well as being an informative hobby, using the forums was a way to meet and chat with like-minded people. If a user was a member of multiple news groups, this information could be found on their profile. One day, Celia was looking at the profile of another.
不足以填满她的日子。西莉亚喜欢浏览 Usenet 系统中的新闻组。新闻组的运作方式与消息论坛相同，有专门针对各种主题的独立小组，如流行文化、音乐、旅行等等。西莉亚主要关注历史新闻组，她对中世纪历史特别感兴趣。使用论坛不仅是一种增长见识的爱好，也是结识志同道合的人并与他们聊天的一种方式。如果用户是多个新闻组的成员，这些信息可以在他们的个人资料中找到。一天，西莉亚正在查看另一个人的个人资料。
the regular poster when she noticed they belonged to a second group called alt.suicide. Dot Holiday, also known as Ash. The strange name caught Celia's attention. She had no idea there were forums for people who wanted to discuss killing themselves, and she was shocked. Out of pure curiosity, Celia hovered her mouse over the link, then clicked on it. Celia Blay had never contemplated suicide herself, but she knew how it felt to be depressed.
当她注意到这位常客属于第二个名为 alt.suicide.holiday（简称 Ash）的小组时，她正在查看该用户的个人资料。这个奇怪的名字引起了西莉亚的注意。她不知道还有专门供那些想讨论自杀的人使用的论坛，她感到非常震惊。出于纯粹的好奇，西莉亚将鼠标悬停在链接上，然后点击了它。西莉亚·布雷本人从未考虑过自杀，但她知道抑郁是什么感觉。
The recent deaths of her parents had plunged Celia into an intense grieving period, leaving her battling some very painful feelings and low moods. As Celia began to explore the Ash Forum, she saw that many of the users were experiencing extreme sadness and suicidal thoughts. Some individuals weren't suicidal themselves, but offered psychological support to those who were. Others were trolls who seemed to enjoy mocking and goading the suicidal forum users. In addition to talking about their desire to end their lives,
父母最近的去世让西莉亚陷入了强烈的悲伤期，使她不得不与一些非常痛苦的情绪和低落的心情作斗争。当西莉亚开始探索 Ash 论坛时，她发现许多用户都在经历极度的悲伤和自杀念头。有些人自己并没有自杀倾向，但会为那些有自杀倾向的人提供心理支持。另一些人则是“喷子”，他们似乎很喜欢嘲笑和怂恿论坛里有自杀倾向的用户。除了谈论他们结束生命的愿望外，
posters debated the larger philosophical issues around life and death. Celia was a compassionate person and her heart went out to these people who were suffering. Identifying with some of the feelings users were describing, she also found some comfort in knowing she wasn't alone. While some of the conversations were too dark for Celia's liking, she was engaged by the deep discussions and thoughtful responses. Celia began to post on the board too and quickly made connections with other regulars. Some of the individuals were teenagers who had their whole lives ahead of them,
发帖者还会辩论围绕生命和死亡的更宏大的哲学问题。西莉亚是一个富有同情心的人，她对这些受苦的人深表同情。由于认同用户描述的一些感受，她也从知道自己并不孤单中找到了一些安慰。虽然有些对话对西莉亚来说太阴暗了，但她被那些深刻的讨论和深思熟虑的回复所吸引。西莉亚也开始在论坛上发帖，并很快与其他常客建立了联系。其中一些人是正值青春年华的青少年，
yet couldn't see the possibility of a bright future. As a former teacher, Celia particularly felt for these young people. She reached out to them and encouraged them to think positively, assuring them that life would get better. One of the posters Celia began to correspond with regularly was a 17-year-old girl from Central America called Anna, not her real name. Anna was a survivor of sexual abuse, had very low self-esteem and was deeply depressed. She felt that suicide was the only way out. Celia messaged Anna often, trying to boost her confidence and telling her that depression was a treatable illness for which suicide was not the answer. Celia assured Anna that there were people who could help and encouraged her to speak to her doctor, friends or priest.
却看不到光明未来的可能性。作为一名前教师，西莉亚特别同情这些年轻人。她主动联系他们，鼓励他们积极思考，向他们保证生活会好起来的。西莉亚开始定期通信的发帖者之一是一位来自中美洲的 17 岁女孩，名叫安娜（化名）。安娜是性虐待的幸存者，自尊心很低，并且患有严重的抑郁症。她觉得自杀是唯一的出路。西莉亚经常给安娜发信息，试图增强她的自信心，并告诉她抑郁症是一种可以治疗的疾病，自杀并不是答案。西莉亚向安娜保证，有人可以帮助她，并鼓励她与医生、朋友或牧师交谈。
Over the course of several weeks, Celia started to feel like she was making progress with Anna. The teenager seemed to be turning a corner. Then one day, Celia received an email from Anna that changed everything. I am going to kill myself at 4 o'clock on Friday, it read. I have made a pact with another girl. Anna explained to Celia that she had been talking with another member of Ash. Her name was Lee Dow and she was a 20-something Chinese-American woman who lived in the stage of of Minnesota. Lee Dow worked as a nurse in a hospital emergency room and had seen patients
在几周的时间里，西莉亚开始觉得她在安娜身上取得了进展。这个青少年似乎正在好转。然后有一天，西莉亚收到了一封来自安娜的电子邮件，一切都改变了。邮件写道：“我将在周五下午 4 点自杀。我已经和另一个女孩达成了协议。”安娜向西莉亚解释说，她一直在和 Ash 的另一名成员交谈。她的名字叫李·道（Lee Dow），是一位 20 多岁的华裔美国女性，住在明尼苏达州。李·道在医院急诊室当护士，见过病人
rushed in after botched suicide attempts. She told Anna that it was very difficult to kill yourself. Many people survived their attempts and had to then live with terrible injuries that sometimes left them incapacitated. Through her nursing work, Lee Dow had concluded that the only surefire way to die by suicide was to hang yourself. She provided Anna with explicit step-by-step instructions on doing so, even telling her what kind of supplies she would need to purchase beforehand. Like Anna, Lee Dow was deeply depressed and suicidal. She suggested that she and Anna end their lives together at the same time. Having someone to go through it would reduce the fear and Lee Dow could make sure Anna was following her directions properly.
在自杀未遂后被紧急送来。她告诉安娜，自杀非常困难。许多人自杀未遂后幸存下来，却不得不带着可怕的伤残生活，有时甚至导致丧失行为能力。通过她的护理工作，李·道得出结论，唯一万无一失的自杀方式是上吊。她为安娜提供了明确的、一步步的操作说明，甚至告诉她事先需要购买什么样的用品。和安娜一样，李·道也患有严重的抑郁症并有自杀倾向。她建议她和安娜在同一时间一起结束生命。有个人一起经历这件事会减少恐惧，而且李·道可以确保安娜正确地按照她的指示去做。
Although Celia was horrified by Anna's revelation, she thought Lee Dow's suggestion sounded absurd, given that she and Anna lived in different countries. Celia replied to Anna immediately, saying, Surely this nurse is not going to travel to Central America to hang herself alongside you? Anna explained that they wouldn't be together in person. Lee Dow had suggested they go online at the same time and turn on their webcams. That way they could watch each other from their respective homes as they hanged themselves at the same time. Celia noticed that Anna sounded somewhat reluctant.
虽然西莉亚对安娜的披露感到震惊，但她认为李·道的建议听起来很荒谬，因为她和安娜住在不同的国家。西莉亚立即回复安娜说：“这个护士肯定不会为了和你一起上吊而跑到中美洲去吧？”安娜解释说，她们不会亲自见面。李·道建议她们在同一时间上网并打开摄像头。这样，她们就可以在各自的家中看着对方，同时上吊。西莉亚注意到安娜听起来有些犹豫。
It seemed that she wasn't certain about wanting to end her life, but she repeatedly said that she didn't want to let down Lee Dow. Celia set about trying to convince Anna to break her pact. Anna's life was far more important than a promise to a stranger online. To Celia's relief, she persuaded Anna not to harm herself. But that wasn't enough for Celia. She was furious that there was an adult out there who would convince a vulnerable teenager to take her own life and assist them in doing so instead of offering her.
似乎她并不确定是否真的想结束自己的生命，但她反复说她不想让李·道失望。西莉亚开始试图说服安娜打破她们的协议。安娜的生命远比对一个网上陌生人的承诺重要。令西莉亚欣慰的是，她劝说安娜不要伤害自己。但这对西莉亚来说还不够。她很愤怒，因为竟然有一个成年人会说服一个脆弱的青少年结束自己的生命，并协助她这样做，而不是提供
or support. Celia began to wonder exactly what sort of person Lee Dow was. There weren't many posts from Lee Dow in the suicide group's main forum. Those she did leave indicated that she had a caring and compassionate personality. She was kind and affectionate with other board members, often referring to people she addressed as Han and assigning off messages with the word hugs. However, on one occasion, Lee Dow had gotten upset with someone who suggested that people who were suicidal should seek refuge in substance abuse instead of death. Another comment from Lee Dow indicated that she was a practicing Christian.
或支持。西莉亚开始好奇李·道到底是什么样的人。在自杀小组的主论坛上，李·道的帖子并不多。她留下的那些帖子表明她有着关怀和富有同情心的人格。她对其他论坛成员很友善和亲切，经常称呼她交谈的人为“Han”，并用“拥抱”一词结束留言。然而，有一次，李·道对一个建议有自杀倾向的人应该通过药物滥用来寻求避难而不是死亡的人感到不满。李·道的另一条评论表明她是一位虔诚的基督徒。
Quote, The hope of eternal life is promised to those who believe. This perspective was somewhat rare within the group's community, with many users stating, they were disillusioned with organized religion. It also seemed odd that a professed Christian would be in favour of suicide when the religion expressly forbids it. Outside of these occasional public posts, it seemed that Lee Dow primarily communicated with other users via direct message. In March of 2006, a user going by the handle Half Jacket had posted, Please someone help me die some way that is quick and or paint.
引用：“永生的希望是应许给那些相信的人的。”这种观点在小组社区中相当罕见，许多用户表示他们对有组织的宗教感到幻灭。一个自称基督徒的人竟然支持自杀，而宗教明确禁止自杀，这似乎也很奇怪。除了这些偶尔的公开帖子外，李·道似乎主要通过私信与其他用户交流。2006 年 3 月，一位网名为“Half Jacket”的用户发帖称：“请有人帮帮我，用一种快速和/或无痛的方式死去。”
directly. I'll do anything. Please, I just need help. Lee Dow had replied to this message, simply writing, check your email. Several months later in July, a user calling himself a Jim said he planned to hang himself and was seeking advice on how to do so correctly. Lee Dow once again responded with the words, Check your email. Celia Blay had a suspicion that something untoward was going on. Due to her lack of experience with the internet, she asked her son Paul to help her dig deeper into Lee Dow's forum posts. With Paul's assistance, Celia tracked down more and more messages that Lee Dow had left in the forum. It looked like she had struck up private conversations with dozens of other users. But what troubled Celia most was that sometimes
“直接告诉我。我什么都愿意做。求求你，我只需要帮助。”李·道回复了这条消息，只写了：“检查你的电子邮件。”几个月后的 7 月，一位自称“Jim”的用户说他计划上吊自杀，并寻求如何正确操作的建议。李·道再次回复道：“检查你的电子邮件。”西莉亚·布雷怀疑有什么不妥的事情正在发生。由于她缺乏互联网经验，她请儿子保罗帮她深入挖掘李·道的论坛帖子。在保罗的帮助下，西莉亚追踪到了李·道在论坛上留下的越来越多的信息。看起来她已经与数十名其他用户建立了私人对话。但最让西莉亚困扰的是，有时
after a user befriended Lee Dow, they then disappeared entirely. In early 2006, a 22-year-old researcher from Croatia named Nicola took to Ash to share some thoughts he'd had about taking his own life. Within two hours of sharing the post, Nicola had a reply from Lee Dow telling him to check his email. In a private message, Lee Dow told Nicola that she knew exactly how he felt. For more than a decade, she'd been struggling with depression and bipolar disorder. Despite going to therapy, taking medication and seeking strength from her religious faith, her circumstances never seemed to improve.
在用户与李·道成为朋友后，他们就完全消失了。2006 年初，一名来自克罗地亚的 22 岁研究员尼古拉（Nicola）在 Ash 论坛上分享了他关于结束自己生命的一些想法。在发帖后的两小时内，尼古拉就收到了李·道的回复，告诉他检查电子邮件。在私信中，李·道告诉尼古拉，她完全理解他的感受。十多年来，她一直饱受抑郁症和双相情感障碍的折磨。尽管接受了治疗、服药并从宗教信仰中寻求力量，但她的情况似乎从未好转。
Lee Dow told Nicola, I'm really tired of living a false life and pretending everything is okay when it is not, and I can't do it anymore. The two began conversing more frequently and over the course of six, six months, they grew close. Nicola found comfort in knowing there was someone else who could relate to how he felt. Lee Dow assured him that he wasn't alone, but she didn't have plans to stick around. Lee Dow confided in Nicola that she was planning to take her own life by hanging.
李·道告诉尼古拉：“我真的厌倦了过虚假的生活，假装一切都好，其实不然，我再也受不了了。”两人开始更频繁地交谈，在六个月的时间里，他们变得亲密起来。尼古拉从知道还有人能理解他的感受中找到了安慰。李·道向他保证他并不孤单，但她并不打算留下来。李·道向尼古拉吐露，她计划通过上吊结束自己的生命。
She told him that she'd been practicing it in private. If Nicola was serious about wanting to die, Lee Dow encouraged him to hang himself too. She claimed it was the quickest and easiest method. Lee Dow provided instructions and suggested they enter into a suicide pact together. Nicola agreed. A date was set but Nicola found he couldn't go through with it. As well as being scared of the pain, he feared what awaited him after death.
她告诉他，她一直在私下练习。如果尼古拉真的想死，李·道鼓励他也上吊。她声称这是最快、最简单的方法。李·道提供了说明，并建议他们一起达成自杀协议。尼古拉同意了。日期定下了，但尼古拉发现自己无法执行。除了害怕痛苦之外，他还害怕死后等待他的是什么。
He admitted to Lee Dow. that he was worried there might be nothing afterwards, and the thought of that terrified him. Lee Dow reassured Nicola that God was real and so was heaven, and encouraged him to convert to Christianity. Nicola and Lee Dow set more dates for their suicide pact, but each time Nicola found himself unable to participate. Then in September 2006, other posters began wondering, where Lee Dow was after she suddenly stopped posting in the public forum. One person begged her to reach out if she was alive and well, while another deduced that she must have finally taken her life.
他向李·道承认，他担心死后可能什么都没有，这个想法让他感到恐惧。李·道向尼古拉保证上帝是真实的，天堂也是真实的，并鼓励他皈依基督教。尼古拉和李·道又定下了几个自杀协议的日期，但每次尼古拉都发现自己无法参与。然后，在 2006 年 9 月，其他发帖者开始纳闷，李·道在突然停止在公共论坛发帖后去了哪里。一个人恳求她如果还活着就联系大家，而另一个人推断她一定最终结束了自己的生命。
Nicola reassured them that Lee Dow was fine. He had heard from her just two days earlier. He added that she was still alive because, quote, We kind of promised to each other to do it the same day. She is ready to die. She is just waiting for me to be ready. Another user soon replied, writing, She told you that too. Oi. It seemed that Lee Dow had entered into suicide packs with multiple people.
尼古拉向他们保证李·道很好。他两天前刚收到她的消息。他补充说她还活着，因为“我们算是答应了对方在同一天做这件事。她准备好去死了。她只是在等我准备好。”另一位用户很快回复道：“她也对你这么说吗？哎呀。”看来李·道已经与多个人达成了自杀协议。
These packs were scheduled for different days and different times. It was unclear why she had done this. The following day, Nicola received an email from a woman. claiming to be Lee Dow's mother. Using her daughter's account, she told Nicola that she had found Lee's body hanging in their basement at 6.40 that morning. Although the family was devastated by her loss, they found comfort in knowing her pain was finally over. Nicola was bereft that Lee Dow was gone and grew even more determined to take his own life. Two months later, he logged on to the Ash Forum and read something shocking.
这些协议安排在不同的日子和不同的时间。目前还不清楚她为什么要这样做。第二天，尼古拉收到了一位自称是李·道母亲的女性发来的电子邮件。她使用女儿的账户告诉尼古拉，她那天早上 6 点 40 分发现李的尸体吊在地下室里。虽然家人对她的离世感到悲痛欲绝，但他们从知道她的痛苦终于结束中找到了安慰。尼古拉对李·道的离去感到悲痛，并更加坚定了结束自己生命的决心。两个月后，他登录 Ash 论坛，读到了一些令人震惊的内容。
One of the other posters had received a message from Lee Dow. She was still alive. Nicola realized he'd been lied to. He posted in the forum, quote, It's not Lee, she doesn't exist. It's some purve fucking with us. Other users agreed. Upon comparing notes, they discovered that Lee Dow had
另一位发帖者收到了李·道的消息。她还活着。尼古拉意识到自己被骗了。他在论坛上发帖说：“那不是李，她根本不存在。是个变态在耍我们。”其他用户也表示同意。在对比了信息后，他们发现李·道
always recommended people kill themselves by hanging, and always suggested they take their lives together via webcam. One individual who had regularly exchanged private messages with Lee Dow said she was always trying to convince him to hang himself. He'd wanted to talk with her over the phone, but she always had some excuse why that wasn't possible. This poster told the other forum members, I believe Lee Dow got some kind of hold. or rush from trying to convince people to die. Celia Blay agreed. Her private investigation into Lee Dow's messages coincided with the other forum members
总是建议人们通过上吊自杀，并且总是建议他们通过摄像头一起结束生命。一位经常与李·道交换私信的人说，她总是试图说服他上吊。他曾想通过电话与她交谈，但她总是有各种借口说这不可能。这位发帖者告诉其他论坛成员：“我相信李·道从试图说服人们去死中获得了一种快感或刺激。”西莉亚·布雷表示同意。她对李·道信息的私人调查与论坛其他成员
realizing what was really going on. Word spread on Ash that Celia was looking into Lee Dow, and soon she received a tip-off that Lee was now using another handle, Falcon Girl. Celia conducted a search for messages posted under that use. username and immediately noted that Falcon Girl's style bore a striking similarity to Lee Dow's. When users posted publicly about their desire to end their life, Falcon Girl replied with the familiar instruction, Check your email.
意识到真相的时间不谋而合。Ash 论坛上传出消息，西莉亚正在调查李·道，很快她就收到线报，说李现在正在使用另一个账号，叫“Falcon Girl”。西莉亚对以该用户名发布的帖子进行了搜索，并立即注意到 Falcon Girl 的风格与李·道惊人地相似。当用户公开谈论他们结束生命的愿望时，Falcon Girl 会回复熟悉的指令：“检查你的电子邮件。”
Celia was determined to put a stop to this. She began reaching out to forum members who had been contacted by Lee Dow. Celia was disturbed by how young some of the members were. One was a schoolboy, while another was a 12-year-old girl. Celia asked Lee's friends if they would let her access their chat logs with the nurse. She wanted to alert the authorities as to what was going on, and promised to keep the identities of all the forum members private. 30 people agreed to Celia's terms and sent her records of their conversations with Lee Dow.
西莉亚决心阻止这一切。她开始联系那些被李·道联系过的论坛成员。西莉亚对其中一些成员的年轻程度感到不安。一个是中学生，另一个是 12 岁的女孩。西莉亚问李的朋友们是否愿意让她查看他们与这位护士的聊天记录。她想提醒当局正在发生的事情，并承诺对所有论坛成员的身份保密。30 人同意了西莉亚的条件，并把他们与李·道的对话记录发给了她。
After collating this information, Celia left her quiet Berkshire village and headed for the nearest police station in Maidenhead. A quaint and leafy market town that sits on the River Thames, Maidenhead had a low crime rate and was ranked as one of England's safest places. When Celia entered the police station with her brief of evidence, she asked to see the officer in charge of online crimes. She ran him through the information she gathered, stating, Look, this person is trying to get people to kill themselves. But the officer didn't seem interested. He dismissed Lee Dow's messages as those of an online troll who was simply trying to wind people up.
整理好这些信息后，西莉亚离开了她安静的伯克郡村庄，前往最近的梅登黑德警察局。梅登黑德是一个坐落在泰晤士河畔、古朴而绿树成荫的集镇，犯罪率很低，被评为英国最安全的地方之一。当西莉亚带着她的证据摘要走进警察局时，她要求见负责网络犯罪的警官。她向他介绍了她收集的信息，并说：“看，这个人正在试图诱导人们自杀。”但警官似乎并不感兴趣。他把李·道的信息斥为网络喷子的行为，只是想激怒别人。
Celia could tell her concerns weren't going to be taken seriously. As she made her way out of the station, an officer remarked, If it bothers you, look the other way. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. More than a year later, on the morning of Monday, March 10, 2008,
西莉亚看得出来，她的担忧不会被认真对待。当她走出警察局时，一名警官评论道：“如果这让你困扰，那就别管它。”Case File 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供高质量的内容。一年多后，2008 年 3 月 10 日星期一早上，
students at Carlton University in the Canadian capital of Ottawa complained about loud music that had been blasting from a dorm room all night long. The dorm room in question belonged to 18-year-old Naja Kuji, a first-year-st-st-year-old majoring in public affairs and policy. Naja was known as a happy, outgoing and confident person, with an independent streak and a passion for politics. When campus security arrived at Naja's dorm room, they found it was empty. Naja was gone, and so was her winter coat and cell phone.
加拿大首都渥太华卡尔顿大学的学生们抱怨说，一间宿舍整晚都在播放大声的音乐。这间宿舍属于 18 岁的娜嘉·库吉（Naja Kuji），一名主修公共事务和政策的一年级学生。娜嘉以快乐、外向和自信而闻名，性格独立，对政治充满热情。当校园保安到达娜嘉的宿舍时，发现里面空无一人。娜嘉不见了，她的冬大衣和手机也不见了。
However, her iPod was still there, paused in the middle of playing a song, and so was her wallet. It contained her driver's license, credit cards, and more than $200 cash. There were no clues as to where Naja might be, but the fact that she'd left her wallet behind seemed to indicate she hadn't planned on staying away for long. Meanwhile, more than 300 miles away in Toronto, Naga's parents were desperately trying to reach her. They called Naja repeatedly, but she didn't answer her phone. Two days later, on Wednesday, March 12, they received a call from Carlton University's security department. They were checking to see whether Naja had gone home for a visit, as she hadn't been seen by anyone on campus for three days.
然而，她的 iPod 还在那里，暂停在播放一首歌的状态，她的钱包也在。里面有她的驾照、信用卡和 200 多美元现金。没有任何线索表明娜嘉可能在哪里，但她留下钱包的事实似乎表明她没打算离开太久。与此同时，在 300 多英里外的多伦多，娜嘉的父母正拼命地试图联系她。他们多次给娜嘉打电话，但她没有接听。两天后，即 3 月 12 日星期三，他们接到了卡尔顿大学保安部门的电话。他们正在核实娜嘉是否回家探亲了，因为校园里已经三天没人见过她了。
Naja's parents were stunned that it had taken so long for the university to reach out to them. They hadn't seen Naja since the previous month and insisted that security and Ottawa police start looking for their daughter, certain that she'd fallen victim to foul play. Naja's father, Muhammad, and brother Mark, made the long journey to Ottawa so they could search for Naja themselves. They also offered a $50,000 reward for her safe return. Meanwhile, police began their own investigation. The only clue they had to Narja's whereabouts lay in an email she'd sent to a friend on the evening of Sunday, March 9. In it, she mentioned that she was about to head out to go ice skating.
娜嘉的父母对大学花了这么长时间才联系他们感到震惊。他们自上个月以来就没见过娜嘉，并坚持要求保安和渥太华警方开始寻找他们的女儿，确信她遭遇了不测。娜嘉的父亲穆罕默德和兄弟马克长途跋涉来到渥太华，以便亲自寻找娜嘉。他们还悬赏 5 万美元以求她平安归来。与此同时，警方开始了他们自己的调查。他们掌握的关于娜嘉下落的唯一线索是她 3 月 9 日星期日晚上发给朋友的一封电子邮件。在邮件中，她提到她正准备去滑冰。
Although it was almost spring, Ottawa was experiencing one of the harshest winters ever recorded. The city was still blanketed with fresh snowfall and to the nearby Rito River. was frozen over. Ice skating was a popular pastime for Carlton University students and also a means of transportation. Investigators searched Naja's dorm room and sure enough, her ice skates were one of the few items missing. Stuck to one wall was a note Naja had written to herself which read, Don't forget to love your life. They seized a number of Naja's personal belongings, including her computer. As investigators scoured the computer for clues, they came across a number of videos Naja had made. In them, Naja sat in her dorm room in front of her webcam and spoke about her life.
虽然快到春天了，但渥太华正经历有记录以来最严酷的冬天之一。城市仍然覆盖着新鲜的积雪，附近的里多河也结冰了。滑冰是卡尔顿大学学生的一项流行消遣，也是一种交通方式。调查人员搜查了娜嘉的宿舍，果然，她的冰鞋是少数几件丢失的物品之一。墙上贴着一张娜嘉写给自己的便条，上面写着：“别忘了热爱你的生活。”他们查封了娜嘉的一些个人物品，包括她的电脑。当调查人员在电脑中搜寻线索时，他们发现了娜嘉制作的一些视频。在视频中，娜嘉坐在宿舍的摄像头前，谈论着她的生活。
She hadn't published these videos anywhere online, instead opting to keep them as a private way of processing and talking through her feelings. Early videos seemed upbeat, with Naja modeling different outfits that she liked. But then they took a turn. When Naja started college, she had broken up with her high school boyfriend and soon met someone new. She fell head over hills for her new boyfriend, but her feelings weren't reciprocated. He had ended the relationship, leaving Naja devastated. Her suffering intensified when she discovered she was pregnant. Naja wasn't ready to become a mother and didn't. know what to do. Then she suddenly miscarried. The experience left Naja feeling as though she had
她没有在网上发布这些视频，而是选择将它们作为处理和倾诉感受的私人方式。早期的视频看起来很乐观，娜嘉展示了她喜欢的不同服装。但随后情况发生了转变。娜嘉上大学时，与高中男友分手，很快遇到了新的人。她对新男友坠入爱河，但她的感情并没有得到回报。他结束了这段关系，让娜嘉悲痛欲绝。当她发现自己怀孕时，她的痛苦加剧了。娜嘉还没准备好成为一名母亲，不知道该怎么办。然后她突然流产了。这次经历让娜嘉觉得她
no control over her own body or destiny. As she described in one video diary entry, quote, I didn't want to get pregnant, I didn't choose to get pregnant, the condom broke, I took the morning after pill and it failed. So I was pregnant and had no choice in the matter. And, then I miscarried, so I couldn't choose whether to keep the child or not keep the child, go through with the pregnancy, not go through with it. Naja was heartbroken and deeply depressed. Her support network of family and friends lived hundreds of miles away. When she visited over Christmas, her family noticed her low mood. When she returned to college, Naja found it impossible to focus on her studies or sleep at night.
对自己的身体或命运毫无掌控力。正如她在一段视频日记中所描述的那样，引用：“我不想怀孕，我没有选择怀孕，避孕套破了，我吃了事后避孕药，但失败了。所以我怀孕了，对此别无选择。然后我流产了，所以我无法选择是留下孩子还是不留下孩子，是继续怀孕还是不继续怀孕。”娜嘉心碎且深陷抑郁。她的家人和朋友支持网络远在数百英里之外。当她圣诞节回家探亲时，家人注意到了她低落的情绪。当她回到大学时，娜嘉发现自己无法专注于学业或在晚上入睡。
Naja made appointments to see a psychiatrist and was prescribed antidepressants. She began self-medicating with alcohol and spent more and more time holed up in her dorm room. Friends said she would lock the door and refused to answer it when they knocked. When she did occasionally emerge, the expression in her eyes was vacant, as though she wasn't quite present. Naja's school grades plunged and it looked as though she would fail, her second semester. Day-to-day functioning felt impossible for the 18-year-old.
娜嘉预约了精神科医生，并开了抗抑郁药。她开始用酒精进行自我治疗，并花越来越多的时间躲在宿舍里。朋友们说她会锁上门，敲门也不回应。当她偶尔出来时，眼神空洞，仿佛她并不完全在场。娜嘉的学业成绩一落千丈，看起来她第二学期要挂科了。对于这位 18 岁的年轻人来说，日常的生活功能似乎变得不可能。
She talked to wearing an eye mask in her video diaries, hiding her face while she spoke about her pain. In one recording, Naja detailed just how much she was struggling, stating, I am depressed, I have postpartum mood disorder, clinical depression and insomnia. Yes, I've thought about suicide. What a shocker. As police dug deeper into Naja's computer activity,
她在视频日记中戴着眼罩，在谈论痛苦时遮住脸。在一段录音中，娜嘉详细描述了她挣扎的程度，说道：“我抑郁了，我有产后情绪障碍、临床抑郁症和失眠症。是的，我想过自杀。多令人震惊啊。”随着警方深入挖掘娜嘉的电脑活动，
they discovered that she'd visited the website alt.suicide.holiday and searched for information on how to kill herself. During her brief period on the website, Naja had befriended another poster in her 20s named Kami D. The two had started contacting each other privately. I wonder how it would feel to actually die, Naja Mee. mused in one message. Nice, Cammy D replied.
他们发现她访问了 alt.suicide.holiday 网站，并搜索了关于如何自杀的信息。在网站上短暂的期间，娜嘉结识了另一位 20 多岁的发帖者，名叫 Cammy D。两人开始私下联系。娜嘉在一条信息中沉思道：“我想知道真正死去是什么感觉。”Cammy D 回复道：“很好。”
When Naja asked Cammy to share her story, Cammy explained. Well, I've had severe depression for 12 years. Meds, therapy, yoga, prayers, nothing has helped me get any better. So about eight months or so ago, I started looking for methods to let go with. And since I've seen every method possible used, I know what does and doesn't work. So that's why I chose hanging. Cammy D told Naja she was a nurse employed in an emergency room. During the course of her work, she'd seen the terrible results of suicide attempts that hadn't worked.
当娜嘉请 Cammy 分享她的故事时，Cammy 解释说：“嗯，我患有严重的抑郁症 12 年了。药物、治疗、瑜伽、祈祷，什么都不能帮我好转。所以大约八个月前，我开始寻找离开的方法。既然我已经见过所有可能的方法，我知道什么有效，什么无效。这就是为什么我选择了上吊。”Cammy D 告诉娜嘉她是一名在急诊室工作的护士。在她的工作中，她见过自杀未遂的可怕后果。
She wrote, quote, I'm not trying to scare you, don't get me wrong. I've seen tons of failed overdoses and bad wrist cuttings and some failed jumpers. In seven years, I've never seen a failed hand. hanging. That's why I chose it. She repeatedly told Naja that death by hanging was guaranteed, quick, and pain-free. Naja said she planned to take her life on the coming Sunday. Kami asked her, you want to use hanging too.
她写道，引用：“我不是想吓唬你，别误会。我见过无数次服药过量失败、割腕严重和跳楼失败的案例。七年来，我从未见过上吊失败的。这就是为什么我选择了它。”她反复告诉娜嘉，上吊死亡是有保证的、快速且无痛的。娜嘉说她计划在接下来的周日结束生命。Cammy 问她：“你也想用上吊吗？”
Naja responded that she planned to jump into the frozen Rito River while wearing her ice gates. She'd noticed a break in the river's ice right beneath the bridge. The water below was rough and she suspected it would carry her under the ice, drowning her. If that didn't work, the below freezing temperatures would give her hypothermia. Naja wanted her death to look like an accident as she felt that would lessen her family's suffering. Cammy wasn't convinced. She told Naja she had seen terrible injuries in people who had tried to die by jumping. If you wanted to do hanging, we could have done it together online, so it would not have been so scary for you, she said.
娜嘉回应说，她计划穿着冰鞋跳进结冰的里多河。她注意到桥下方的冰面有一个裂口。下面的水流湍急，她怀疑它会把她带到冰下，淹死她。如果那不起作用，零度以下的温度会导致她体温过低。娜嘉希望她的死看起来像一场意外，因为她觉得这会减轻家人的痛苦。Cammy 不以为然。她告诉娜嘉，她见过试图跳楼自杀的人受到的可怕伤害。“如果你想上吊，我们可以一起在网上做，这样你就不会那么害怕了，”她说。
Then she provided detailed instructions. Naja and Kami spoke again a few days later on Sunday, March 9, the last day that Naja had been seen alive. Naja told Kami she planned to go out later that night to carry out her plan. Kami didn't try to convince Naja that her life was worth saving. Instead, she again tried to convince Naja to hang herself via webcam with her. Naja resisted Kami's urging and later that night, she left her dorm room and disappeared into the cold Ottawa night. Police printed out the transcripts of Naja's online conversations for her parents to see. They were shocked.
然后她提供了详细的说明。娜嘉和 Cammy 几天后，即 3 月 9 日星期日，也就是娜嘉最后一次被看到活着的那天，再次交谈。娜嘉告诉 Cammy 她计划那天晚上晚些时候出去执行她的计划。Cammy 没有试图说服娜嘉她的生命值得拯救。相反，她再次试图说服娜嘉通过摄像头与她一起上吊。娜嘉抵制了 Cammy 的催促，那天晚上晚些时候，她离开了宿舍，消失在寒冷的渥太华之夜。警方打印了娜嘉的在线对话记录给她的父母看。他们震惊了。
They had known Naja wasn't her usual cheerful self when they'd last seen her, but didn't realize how depressed she'd actually been. Naja had confided in her mother about her unplanned pregnancy and miscarriage. However, she had concealed her struggle with insomnia, her ongoing appointments with the psychiatrist, and that she'd started discussing suicide with other people online. Naga's parents realized that their initial suspicions about Naja falling victim, to foul play had been wrong.
他们知道娜嘉上次见到他们时并不是她平时开朗的样子，但没有意识到她实际上有多抑郁。娜嘉曾向母亲吐露过她意外怀孕和流产的事。然而，她隐瞒了她与失眠的斗争、她与精神科医生的持续预约，以及她开始在网上与其他人讨论自杀的事。娜嘉的父母意识到他们最初关于娜嘉遭遇不测的怀疑是错误的。
For them, the knowledge that their daughter had seemingly taken her own life was more painful than believing she might be held somewhere against her will, as it eliminated all hope. Police realised that Naja Kajuji's body most likely lay somewhere in or near the Rideau River, but her three-foot blanket of snow had fallen over Ottawa, hampering the search efforts. In the weeks following Naja's disappearance, her parents learnt that while they had been in the dark about their daughter's depression, her university had not. Several months earlier, Naja had gone to a local restaurant carrying a razor blade. She told people in the restaurant that if somebody didn't help her, she was going to hurt herself. An ambulance was called and Naja was taken to hospital.
对他们来说，得知女儿似乎结束了自己的生命，比相信她可能被关在某个地方更痛苦，因为它消除了所有的希望。警方意识到娜嘉·库吉的尸体很可能躺在里多河中或附近，但渥太华下了三英尺厚的积雪，阻碍了搜寻工作。在娜嘉失踪后的几周里，她的父母得知，虽然他们对女儿的抑郁症一无所知，但她的大学却并非如此。几个月前，娜嘉曾带着一把剃须刀去了一家当地餐馆。她告诉餐馆里的人，如果有人不帮她，她就会伤害自己。救护车被叫来，娜嘉被送往医院。
On another occasion, one of Naja's roommates had contacted campus security to alert them of their belief that Naja was suicidal. Naja had told her psychiatrist that she was suicidal and had considered multiple ways that she might take her own life. Naga's parents were distraught. They didn't understand why they hadn't been informed about these events, or why it had taken the university two days to call them after Naja disdural. disappeared. University officials responded that confidentiality laws prevented them from reaching out to a student's parents. The university's vice president for student support services released a statement that they had reviewed all the actions the institution had taken in response to Naja's situation, and, quote, we really feel that we've done everything that we could. Six weeks after Naja vanished,
另一次，娜嘉的一位室友联系了校园保安，提醒他们认为娜嘉有自杀倾向。娜嘉曾告诉她的精神科医生她有自杀倾向，并考虑过多种结束自己生命的方法。娜嘉的父母心烦意乱。他们不明白为什么他们没有被告知这些事件，或者为什么大学在娜嘉失踪两天后才给他们打电话。大学官员回应说，保密法禁止他们联系学生的父母。大学负责学生支持服务的副校长发表声明称，他们已经审查了该机构为应对娜嘉的情况所采取的所有行动，并引用：“我们真的觉得我们已经尽了我们所能。”娜嘉失踪六周后，
the snow around Ottawa started to thaw. On April 19, 2008, a boater on the Rideau River discovered her body snagged on a rock. She was fully dressed and wearing her ice skates. An autopsy confirmed that Naga had died from either drowning or hypothermia. By this point, Ottawa police had already traced the messages sent by Naja's online friend, Cammy D.
渥太华周围的积雪开始融化。2008 年 4 月 19 日，里多河上的一名船夫发现了她被岩石钩住的尸体。她穿着整齐，穿着冰鞋。尸检证实娜嘉死于溺水或体温过低。此时，渥太华警方已经追踪到了娜嘉的在线朋友 Cammy D 发送的信息。
By looking into the internet protocol or IP address from where the messages had been sent, they determined Kami D lived almost 2,000 kilometres away in Faribu, Minnesota. On March 26, 2008, more than three weeks before Naja Kajuji's body was found, Ottawa Police contacted a law enforcement in Faribou to request a welfare check. They explained that they had information indicating a local resident had done. made a suicide pact with a young woman in Ottawa who was missing and believed to be dead. But when Farabou police went to the address in question, they found that everybody there was alive and well. The day before investigators in Ottawa contacted police in Farabow, a sergeant
通过查看发送信息的互联网协议或 IP 地址，他们确定 Cammy D 住在近 2000 公里外的明尼苏达州法里博。2008 年 3 月 26 日，即娜嘉·库吉的尸体被发现前三周多，渥太华警方联系了法里博的执法部门，要求进行福利检查。他们解释说，他们掌握的信息表明当地一名居民与渥太华一名失踪并被认为已经死亡的年轻女性达成了自杀协议。但当法里博警方前往该地址时，发现那里的人都还活着。在渥太华的调查人员联系法里博警方的前一天，一名警官
in the nearby city of St. Paul received information from a private citizen who had been conducting her own investigation from her home in Berkshire, England. For almost two years, Celia Bley had been hard at work looking into the Ash poster who called herself Lee Dow and later Falcon Girl. Although Celia's first attempt to notify law enforcement had been unsuccessful, she hadn't given up. Celia went out of her way to contact Ash Forum members who'd been messaged by Lee Dow. Celia informed them that Lee Dow was a serial predator who made false suicide packs with vulnerable people due to some sick reason of her own. Celia also left posts in the public forum,
在附近的圣保罗市收到了一位私人公民提供的信息，该公民一直在英国伯克郡的家中进行自己的调查。近两年来，西莉亚·布雷一直在努力调查那个自称李·道（Lee Dow）后来又叫“Falcon Girl”的 Ash 发帖者。虽然西莉亚第一次通知执法部门的尝试没有成功，但她并没有放弃。西莉亚不遗余力地联系了被李·道发过信息的 Ash 论坛成员。西莉亚通知他们，李·道是一个连环掠夺者，出于某种病态的原因，与脆弱的人达成虚假的自杀协议。西莉亚还在公共论坛上发帖，
alerting users to Lee Dow's M-O. Other forum members began reaching out to Celia to report their own encounters with Lee Dow, and she kept an ever-growing list of interactions. In late 2007, Celia's efforts caught the attention of a 35-year-old woman named Cat Lowe. Cat lived in the English city of Wolverhampton and was struggling. She was unemployed and clinically depressed.
提醒用户注意李·道的作案手法。其他论坛成员开始联系西莉亚，报告他们自己与李·道的遭遇，她保留了一份不断增长的互动名单。2007 年底，西莉亚的努力引起了一位名叫凯特·洛（Cat Lowe）的 35 岁女性的注意。凯特住在英国伍尔弗汉普顿市，生活艰难。她失业且患有临床抑郁症。
Her ex had primary custody of her two children, resulting in Kat only seeing them on school holidays. To numb her trauma and distress, Kat self-medicated with heroin. Lately, she'd found a living so difficult that she was considering ending her life. Like so many others, Kat turned to ash. to talk to others who could relate to her pain. One of the people she met there was Falcon Girl. It felt like every time Kat logged on, Falcon Girl would send her a private message, keen to chat. She kept trying to convince Kat that if she wanted to end her life, she should hang herself.
她的前夫拥有她两个孩子的监护权，导致凯特只能在学校假期见到他们。为了麻痹她的创伤和痛苦，凯特用海洛因进行自我治疗。最近，她发现生活太艰难了，以至于她正在考虑结束自己的生命。像许多其他人一样，凯特转向了 Ash 论坛，与那些能理解她痛苦的人交谈。她在那里遇到的人之一就是 Falcon Girl。感觉每次凯特登录，Falcon Girl 都会给她发私信，热衷于聊天。她一直试图说服凯特，如果她想结束生命，她应该上吊。
When a teenage friend of Katz from the forum entered into a suicide pact with Falcon Girl and nearly killed herself, Kat realized that Falcon Girl was a dangerous individual with no qualms about preying on children. She reached out to Celia Blay and offered to help her cause. Kat suggested that she go undercover and befriend Falcon Girl. She would try to coax information from her that might give some indication as to her true identity. Although Kat was scared that Falcon Girl might convince her to take her own life during during the process, she was determined to help where she could. Celia accepted Kat's offer and gifted her a gold crucifix necklace as a symbol of strength.
当凯特在论坛上的一位青少年朋友与 Falcon Girl 达成自杀协议并差点自杀时，凯特意识到 Falcon Girl 是一个危险的人，对掠夺儿童毫无顾忌。她联系了西莉亚·布雷，并提出帮助她的事业。凯特建议她卧底并与 Falcon Girl 成为朋友。她会试图从她那里套出可能暗示她真实身份的信息。虽然凯特害怕 Falcon Girl 可能会在过程中说服她结束自己的生命，但她决心在力所能及的地方提供帮助。西莉亚接受了凯特的提议，并赠送给她一条金十字架项链作为力量的象征。
Kat promised that so long as she was wearing the necklace, she wouldn't attempt suicide. Kat sent Falcon Girl an email saying she wanted to take her own life and needed some advice. Falcon Girl responded. Although she claimed to be 30, instead of in her 20s like Lee Dow, there were many identical features to the Lee Dow messages. Rather than asking if Kat had sought help via therapy or medication, Falcon Girl wrote back with some tips about dying by hanging. She added that having a webcam would help so she could guide Kat remotely when the time came.
凯特承诺，只要她戴着这条项链，她就不会尝试自杀。凯特给 Falcon Girl 发了一封电子邮件，说她想结束自己的生命，需要一些建议。Falcon Girl 回复了。虽然她声称自己 30 岁，而不是像李·道那样 20 多岁，但李·道的信息中有许多相同的特征。Falcon Girl 没有问凯特是否通过治疗或药物寻求过帮助，而是回复了一些关于上吊死亡的技巧。她补充说，有一个摄像头会有帮助，这样当时间到来时，她可以远程指导凯特。
She signed off her message with the word hugs and her name, Cammy D A few days later Cammy emailed Kat again to check in Kat replied that she was trying to find a mental health care professional to help her adding
她用“拥抱”一词和她的名字“Cammy D”结束了她的信息。几天后，Cammy 又给凯特发了电子邮件询问情况。凯特回复说她正在努力寻找心理健康护理专业人员来帮助她，并补充说
If they don't offer me the help I need I can't see any other option than to end it Cammy D wrote back I care and always will I wish we could chat Then she signed off with the word hugs. The two started chatting more and more frequently. Kami repeatedly offered to watch Kat's suicide via webcam if she wanted her to. She also told her about her experience in an emergency
如果他们不提供我需要的帮助，我想不出除了结束生命还有什么别的选择。Cammy D回信说：我关心你，而且永远都会。我真希望我们能聊聊。然后她用“拥抱”这个词结束了对话。两人开始越来越频繁地聊天。Kami多次提出，如果Kat愿意，她可以通过网络摄像头观看Kat自杀。她还向Kat讲述了自己在急诊室的经历，以及那次经历如何让她坚信上吊是最可靠的自杀方式。
room and how it had led her to her belief that hanging was the most dependable suicide method. Cammy D confided in Kat that she had already helped at least four people to hang themselves. Kat asked if Cammy had watched the suicides via webcam, and if she was worried about getting in trouble as a result. Cammy said she'd only watched one, and had done so because the individual hadn't wanted to be alone. He was a 32-year-old man from Birmingham, England. Cammy wasn't concerned about the police chasing her up because she intended to die soon too. She assured Kat that she was finally ready to take her own life and would commit to any suicide-packed they entered together.
Cammy D向Kat吐露，她至少已经帮助过四个人上吊自杀了。Kat问Cammy是否通过网络摄像头观看了这些自杀过程，以及她是否担心因此惹上麻烦。Cammy说她只看过一次，那是因为那个人不想独自一人。那是一个来自英国伯明翰的32岁男子。Cammy并不担心警察会追查她，因为她也打算很快死去。她向Kat保证，她终于准备好结束自己的生命了，并且会致力于他们共同达成的任何自杀协议。
At Kat's request, Kami sent through a photo of herself with what appeared to be her grey-haired husband and two teenage daughters. They posed together, smiling happily on a piano bench. The woman in the photo had short dark hair and was dressed conservatively in a cardigan and high-necked black top. Kat presumed that the woman was Cammy, but found the photo rather odd. Cammy had been telling everyone she was a young woman, but the couple pictured looked to be in their mid-40s at least.
应Kat的要求，Kami发来了一张照片，照片里有她那看起来头发花白的丈夫和两个十几岁的女儿。他们一起坐在钢琴凳上，微笑着，看起来很幸福。照片中的女人留着深色的短发，穿着保守的开衫和黑色高领上衣。Kat推测那个女人就是Cammy，但觉得这张照片很奇怪。Cammy一直告诉大家她是个年轻女性，但照片中的夫妇看起来至少有40多岁。
While Cammy typically offered the people she chatted with reasons why she couldn't use her webcam, Kat finally coaxed Cammy into switching hers on while they talked. Cammy wouldn't sit within sight of the camera's lens, but agreed to keep it on nonetheless. One day, as Cad and Cammy typed back and forth, Kat suddenly noticed something. A person had come into view of Cammy's camera. Cat grabbed her cell phone and managed to quickly snap a photo of the individual before they exited from view.
虽然Cammy通常会向聊天对象找借口说她无法使用网络摄像头，但Kat最终还是说服了Cammy在他们交谈时打开了摄像头。Cammy不愿坐在摄像头镜头能拍到的范围内，但还是同意保持开启。有一天，当Kat和Cammy互相打字时，Kat突然注意到了什么。一个人进入了Cammy摄像头的视野。Kat抓起手机，在对方离开视野之前迅速拍下了一张照片。
The person she'd photographed wasn't the woman from Cammy's picture. It was the man. You're a bloke, Kat. typed. But the man didn't log off. Instead, he asked Kat, Does it matter? Cat replied, no, but she asked why he was pretending to be a young woman. Was this motivated by some sexual desire? The man said no, it was a form of self-protection. He explained that if there were ever any legal ramifications for his helping suicidal people, then the authorities would be searching for a woman, not a man.
她拍到的人并不是Cammy照片里的那个女人。是个男人。Kat打字道：“你是个男人。”但那个男人并没有下线。相反，他问Kat：“这很重要吗？”Kat回答说不重要，但她问他为什么要假装成一个年轻女性。这是出于某种性欲吗？那个男人说不是，这是一种自我保护。他解释说，如果他帮助自杀者而产生任何法律后果，那么当局会寻找一个女人，而不是一个男人。
Kat told Celia Blay about her latest discoveries. At around at the same time, another member of the forum who was experienced in telecommunications helped Celia trace Lee Dow and Cammy D's emails to a server in the Minnesota city of Faribou. Celia finally felt like she was getting closer to making an identification. The final piece of the puzzle came when the man sent an email with a mistake in it. He had included his real name in the subject's header. William Melchert Dinkle. After Melchert Dinkle told Kat Lowe that he'd watched a man in Birmingham suicide on his webcam,
Kat把她的最新发现告诉了Celia Blay。大约在同一时间，论坛里另一位精通电信的成员帮助Celia将Lee Dow和Cammy D的电子邮件追踪到了明尼苏达州法里博市的一个服务器上。Celia终于觉得她离查明身份更近了一步。拼图的最后一块是在那个男人发来的一封邮件中出现的，邮件里有一个错误。他在主题栏里写上了他的真实姓名：William Melchert-Dinkel。在Melchert-Dinkel告诉Kat Lowe他通过网络摄像头观看了一名伯明翰男子的自杀过程后，
Celia drove to the West Midlands to report his claim to the authorities there. She provided them with a CD filled with all the case evidence she'd managed to. to gather so far. But Birmingham Police treated Celia with the same dismissive attitude as the officers in Berkshire. One Birmingham policeman called Celia's husband at their home to check if he knew where his wife was and what she was doing. Celia also tried speaking to an English member of Parliament, but got nowhere once again. In February of 2008, Celia sent an email to the United States Federal Bureau of Investigation or FBI. She hoped that authorities in the country where William Melchard-Dinkle resided
Celia开车前往西米德兰兹郡，向当地当局报告了他的说法。她提供了一张光盘，里面装满了她迄今为止收集到的所有案件证据。但伯明翰警方对待Celia的态度和伯克郡的警官一样，都是不屑一顾。一名伯明翰警察甚至给Celia的丈夫打了电话，询问他是否知道妻子在哪里以及在做什么。Celia还试图联系一位英国议员，但再次碰壁。2008年2月，Celia给美国联邦调查局（FBI）发了一封电子邮件。她希望William Melchert-Dinkel居住国家的当局
might take more of an interest. But, unbeknownst to Celia, the email wasn't received. At her wits end, Celia reached out to an online friend named Mary Jo, who also lived in the state of Minnesota. The pair had met through Celia's small business and bonded over the same. their interest in horses. When Mary Jo heard what Celia had to say about William Melchard Dinkle, she offered to put her in touch with an old friend who worked at the Sheriff's Department. He in turn told Celia to contact Minnesota's Bureau of Criminal Apprehension, which had an entire
可能会更感兴趣。但Celia不知道的是，这封邮件并没有被收到。走投无路的Celia联系了一位住在明尼苏达州的网友Mary Jo。两人是通过Celia的小生意认识的，并因对马匹的共同兴趣而结缘。当Mary Jo听到Celia关于William Melchert-Dinkel的讲述后，她主动提出帮她联系一位在治安官办公室工作的老朋友。那位朋友反过来告诉Celia联系明尼苏达州的刑事侦查局，该局有一个专门的
department dedicated to pursuing adults who targeted children online. In late March 2008, Celia sat down to write another pleading email. The email was opened by Sergeant William Hayder of the St. Paul Police Department, who was on assignment with the Internet Crimes Against Children Task Force. Celia Blay had outlined that there was an online predator who was deliberately deceiving vulnerable people in order to manipulate them into suiciding. She named the predator as Minnesota resident William Melchett Dinkle and included details about his MO and six different aliases he was known to use.
部门负责追查在网上针对儿童的成年人。2008年3月下旬，Celia坐下来写了另一封恳求信。这封邮件被圣保罗警察局的William Hayder警官打开，他当时正受命于“互联网反儿童犯罪特别工作组”。Celia Blay在信中概述说，有一个网络掠夺者正在蓄意欺骗弱势群体，以操纵他们自杀。她指名道姓地指出该掠夺者是明尼苏达州居民William Melchert-Dinkel，并提供了关于他的作案手法和他已知的六个不同化名的详细信息。
Although Sergeant Hayder was taken aback by the bizarre story, he was also intrigued. He took up the case and Celia continued to send him more evidence, including five different email addresses Melchert Dinkel used and chat logs of his conversations. Sergeant Hayder learnt that William Melchert Dinkel was a 46th. six-year-old nurse who was married with two daughters. He hadn't worked in an emergency department like his alter egos, but was employed in a nursing home. In 1994, he gave one resident incorrect medication. In another incident, he failed to document a patient's deteriorating condition, and they later died while on route to a hospital. In 1995, Melchard Dinkle started working in a hospital. In 1995, Melchard Dinkle started working
尽管Hayder警官对这个离奇的故事感到震惊，但他也很感兴趣。他接手了这个案子，Celia继续向他发送更多证据，包括Melchert-Dinkel使用的五个不同的电子邮件地址和他们的聊天记录。Hayder警官了解到，William Melchert-Dinkel是一名46岁的护士，已婚，有两个女儿。他并没有像他的化身那样在急诊科工作，而是在一家疗养院工作。1994年，他给一位住户服用了错误的药物。在另一起事件中，他未能记录一名患者的病情恶化情况，导致该患者在送往医院的途中死亡。1995年，Melchert-Dinkel开始在
in the ortho-neuro unit at St. Paul Hospital, where his poor work performance continued. His inability to retain information became a problem, and he blamed his poor concentration on issues at home. Mellchette Dinkle was subsequently diagnosed with a learning disability and attention deficit disorder. He was put on medication but still felt overwhelmed at work, leading him to resign. He found a job. at another nursing home, where he was found to have abused two residents and was ultimately fired. After this, the Minnesota Board of Nursing limited his licence so he could only work under supervision. He continued to find work in nursing homes, but co-workers complained about his poor skills and
圣保罗医院的骨科神经科工作，在那里他的工作表现依然很差。他无法记住信息成了个问题，他把注意力不集中归咎于家庭问题。Melchert-Dinkel随后被诊断出患有学习障碍和注意力缺陷障碍。他开始服药，但在工作中仍然感到不知所措，最终辞职了。他在另一家疗养院找到了一份工作，在那里他被发现虐待了两名住户，最终被解雇。此后，明尼苏达州护理委员会限制了他的执照，要求他只能在监督下工作。他继续在疗养院找工作，但同事们抱怨他技术差且
rude attitude towards patients. By mid-2008, he was working at his fourth nursing home. On Wednesday, January 7, 2009, Sergeant Hader and two colleagues traveled to William Melchard Dinkle's home in Faribow, Minnesota. It was a white shingled house with black shutters and a perfectly manicured front lawn. Maltzett Dinkle invited the officers into his home. They introduced themselves and said they wished to speak to him regarding some internet-related issues. I think I know what you mean, replied Melchett Dinkle. When the officers asked him to explain his remark, he said he had, quote, Some concerns about some of the internet activity that has been going on here regarding issues with suicide and so forth.
对病人态度粗鲁。到2008年中期，他已经在第四家疗养院工作了。2009年1月7日星期三，Hayder警官和两名同事前往位于明尼苏达州法里博的William Melchert-Dinkel家中。那是一栋带有黑色百叶窗和修剪得完美无缺的前草坪的白色木瓦房。Melchert-Dinkel邀请警官进入家中。他们介绍了自己，并表示想就一些与互联网相关的问题与他谈谈。Melchert-Dinkel回答说：“我想我知道你们指的是什么。”当警官要求他解释这句话时，他说他“对这里发生的一些关于自杀等问题的互联网活动有一些担忧”。
Melchard Dinkle explained that he and his wife both worked in healthcare and that in that capacity, they had conversations with people online about depression and suicide. suicide. Some of the conversations had gotten inappropriate. The officers asked if his wife should be included in the interview. Multure Dinkle then changed tack, admitting that his wife had nothing to do with the online discussions. He, on the other hand, had been acting as a, quote, advisor in suicide methods, dispensing detailed advice about dying by hanging in particular. He admitted to going into particular forums and using various female aliases. According to Melchard Dinkle, he'd stopped doing this the previous month due to moral,
Melchert-Dinkel解释说，他和妻子都在医疗保健行业工作，以这种身份，他们会在网上与人讨论抑郁和自杀问题。有些谈话变得不合适了。警官问他的妻子是否应该参加这次谈话。Melchert-Dinkel随即改变了说法，承认他的妻子与这些在线讨论无关。而他自己，则一直充当着“自杀方法顾问”的角色，散布关于自杀的详细建议，特别是关于上吊自杀的建议。他承认自己会进入特定的论坛并使用各种女性化名。据Melchert-Dinkel称，由于道德、
ethical and legal reasons. The officers asked Melchard Dinkle if he could name anyone he'd had these conversations with. He said he'd spoken to some people in England. He couldn't be certain that they'd died, but he believed so as he'd stopped hearing from them. He also admitted that he'd had a suicide pact with a young woman from Ottawa who had jumped into a frozen river. Her name was Naja Kajuji. Melchit Dinkle had learned of Nadia's suicide after the police in Ottawa traced his emails and had requested a welfare check at his home shortly after Naja disappeared.
伦理和法律原因，他在上个月已经停止了这种行为。警官问Melchert-Dinkel是否能说出他曾与哪些人进行过这些谈话。他说他曾与英国的一些人交谈过。他不能确定他们是否已经死了，但他认为是的，因为他已经不再收到他们的消息了。他还承认，他曾与一名来自渥太华的年轻女子达成过自杀协议，那名女子跳进了一条冰冻的河流。她的名字叫Nadia Kajuji。Melchert-Dinkel是在渥太华警方追踪到他的电子邮件并要求在他家进行福利检查后，才得知Nadia自杀的消息的。
His family had all been away on vacation at the time, but Melchard Dinkle had subsequently confirmed with the police. that they were all alive and well. A few weeks after Narja's body was found, investigators in Ottawa had called Melchert Dinkle at home to follow up on the emails they'd traced. Maltzit Dinkle told them the home computer was used by his two teenage daughters
当时他的家人都在度假，但Melchert-Dinkel随后向警方确认了他们都安然无恙。在Nadia的尸体被发现几周后，渥太华的调查人员曾致电Melchert-Dinkel家中，跟进他们追踪到的电子邮件。Melchert-Dinkel告诉他们，家里的电脑是他两个十几岁的女儿使用的，
and that they used the screen name Falcon Girl. The Falcons were the mascot of the local high school in Faribaut. Multure Dinkle told Ottawa investigators that his daughters must have been the ones conversing with Naja Kajuji. They would have information about suicide due to their mother being a surgical nurse. He was very concerned about their behaviour and said he would make sure the issue was addressed. Sergeant Hader and his colleagues asked Melchard Dinkle to estimate how many people might have suicided as a result of his conversations with them. He said he'd talked about suicide with about 20 people and made suicide packs with about 10. Multure Dinkle later increased that figure to dozens.
她们使用的网名是“Falcon Girl”。“猎鹰”是法里博当地高中的吉祥物。Melchert-Dinkel告诉渥太华的调查人员，一定是他的女儿们在与Nadia Kajuji交谈。由于她们的母亲是外科护士，她们会了解自杀相关的信息。他非常担心她们的行为，并表示他会确保这个问题得到解决。Hayder警官和他的同事要求Melchert-Dinkel估计有多少人可能因为与他的谈话而自杀。他说他曾与大约20人谈论过自杀，并与大约10人达成了自杀协议。Melchert-Dinkel后来将这个数字增加到了几十人。
He guessed that of the people he made packs with, about five had probably died. Multure Dinkle admitted that he knew it was illegal to assist in suicide. He'd seen comments posted in suicide forums that warned others to stay away from him, but he hadn't been scared off. He kept encouraging others to take their lives, telling them that it was okay to let go and they would be better off in heaven. As he put it,
他猜测在他达成协议的人中，大约有五人可能已经死亡。Melchert-Dinkel承认他知道协助自杀是违法的。他曾在自杀论坛上看到过警告他人远离他的评论，但他并没有被吓跑。他继续鼓励他人结束生命，告诉他们放手是可以的，他们在天堂会过得更好。正如他所说，
his caring nature went too far. William Maltchett Dinkle gave the officer's permission to search his home and signed a waiver that would allow them to search his computer as well. After the interview concluded, Melchard Dinkle went to a local hospital and entered the emergency department. He explained to the nurses there that he was under investigation for assisting suicide. He admitted to having an addiction to internet suicide sites
他那“关怀的本性”走得太远了。William Melchert-Dinkel允许警官搜查他的家，并签署了一份弃权书，允许他们搜查他的电脑。采访结束后，Melchert-Dinkel去了当地一家医院并进入了急诊科。他向那里的护士解释说，他因协助自杀正在接受调查。他承认自己对互联网自杀网站有瘾，
and was feeling guilty that he told others how to kill themselves. He explained that the appeal lay in, quote, The Thrill of the Chase. Meanwhile, investigators got to work examining the contents of Melchard Dinkle's computer. They found a photograph of Naja Kajuji and copious messages about suicide from Melchard Dinkle to people he'd met online. All of his correspondence consisted of pro-suicide encouragement and highly detailed information
并且因为告诉别人如何自杀而感到内疚。他解释说，这种吸引力在于“追求的快感”。与此同时，调查人员开始检查Melchert-Dinkel电脑里的内容。他们发现了一张Nadia Kajuji的照片，以及Melchert-Dinkel发给他在网上认识的人的大量关于自杀的信息。他所有的通信内容都包含支持自杀的鼓励和高度详细的
about how to hang oneself. Melchard Dinkle always assured people that hanging was a quick, surefire and painless way to die. But this is not true. Most likely, he had wanted them to use this particular method because it was the way he hoped to watch them die via a webcam. Police found no evidence that Melchard Dinkle had videos of suicide saved on his computer. Miltchard Dinkle had told Kat Lowe that he'd seen one individual hang himself through his webcam, a 32-year-old Englishman from Birmingham.
关于如何上吊的信息。Melchert-Dinkel总是向人们保证，上吊是一种快速、万无一失且无痛的死亡方式。但这并非事实。很可能，他希望他们使用这种特定的方法，因为这是他希望通过网络摄像头观看他们死亡的方式。警方没有发现Melchert-Dinkel的电脑里存有自杀视频的证据。Melchert-Dinkel曾告诉Kat Lowe，他通过网络摄像头看到过一个人上吊自杀，那是一个来自伯明翰的32岁英国人。
When police asked about this, he steadfastly denied it. But he ultimately admitted that there was another 32-year-old man from England who had died as a result of his actions. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. At around 4pm on Wednesday, July 27, 2005, Carol Drybrough drove to her brother Mark's home in Coventry, England. The siblings had planned to meet at a nearby park that
当警方询问此事时，他坚决否认。但他最终承认，确实有另一名来自英国的32岁男子因他的行为而死亡。CaseFile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供优质内容。2005年7月27日星期三下午4点左右，Carol Drybrough开车前往她哥哥Mark在英国考文垂的家。兄妹俩原计划在附近的一个公园见面。
afternoon. When Mark failed to show up, Carol decided to check on him. She knocked on Mark's front door, then waited for an answer. None came, so Carol let herself in. Taped to the inside door, was a note written in block letters that read, Please call the police, do not go upstairs, go home, hand this note to the police. Ignoring the message, Carol raced upstairs. She tried to open Mark's bedroom door, but it was blocked. After pushing forcefully, Carol was able to get in. Inside, she found Mark's body hanging.
那天下午，当Mark没有出现时，Carol决定去看看他。她敲了敲Mark的前门，然后等待回应。没有人应答，于是Carol自己走了进去。贴在门内侧的是一张用印刷体写成的纸条，上面写着：“请报警，不要上楼，回家，把这张纸条交给警察。”Carol无视了这条信息，冲上楼去。她试图打开Mark的卧室门，但门被堵住了。在用力推开后，Carol终于进去了。在里面，她发现了Mark上吊的尸体。
Carol tried to prop him up in an effort to save him while simultaneously calling for an ambulance. She held his weight up the entire time that she waited for paramedics to arrive. Tragically, it was too late and Mark Adreibera had already passed. As a child and teenager, Mark had been mischievous with a great sense of humour. At university, he flourished while studying computer engineering and found happiness. with a girlfriend. But then Mark contracted glandular fever, which left him with chronic fatigue. From there, his life started to fall apart. His relationship ended and he lost motivation to attend classes, eventually dropping out. Over the next 10 years, Mark battled depression and extreme
Carol试图支撑住他以挽救他的生命，同时呼叫救护车。在等待医护人员到达的整个过程中，她一直托着他的体重。悲剧的是，一切都太晚了，Mark Drybrough已经去世了。作为孩子和青少年，Mark一直很调皮，很有幽默感。在大学里，他学习计算机工程，成绩优异，并找到了一个女朋友，生活得很幸福。但后来Mark患上了腺热，导致他患上了慢性疲劳综合症。从那时起，他的生活开始分崩离析。他的恋情结束了，他失去了上课的动力，最终退学了。在接下来的10年里，Mark一直在与抑郁症和极度的
exhaustion. Although he was prescribed medication, he sometimes stopped taking it and suffered from psychotic fits. His mother Elaine provided financial support, but Mark had little independence, no social life, and low self-esteem. While his death was presumed to be suicide, police still attended the scene and took photographs for an official inquest. Although Mark's family were aware of his depression, they didn't know that he was suicidal. They were desperate to understand why he had done what he did. In the weeks leading up to his death, his mother Elaine had noticed that Mark had been spending more and more time on his computer. She and Mark's sister Carol began wondering if the answers to their grief might be found in Mark's online activity. Carol logged on to his computer
疲惫作斗争。虽然他开了药，但他有时会停药，并遭受精神病发作的折磨。他的母亲Elaine提供了经济支持，但Mark几乎没有独立性，没有社交生活，自尊心也很低。虽然他的死亡被推定为自杀，但警方还是赶到了现场并拍摄了照片，以进行正式的死因调查。虽然Mark的家人知道他患有抑郁症，但他们并不知道他有自杀倾向。他们迫切想知道他为什么会这样做。在他去世前的几周里，他的母亲Elaine注意到Mark在电脑上花费的时间越来越多。她和Mark的妹妹Carol开始怀疑，他们悲痛的答案可能隐藏在Mark的在线活动中。Carol登录了他的电脑，
and began trawling through his internet history. She discovered that earlier that month, on July 1, Mark had posted in a forum dedicated to discussions about suicide. Using the handle spooky, he asked. Does anyone have details of hanging methods where there is an access to anything high up to tie the rope to? I've read that people have taken their own lives in jail. Anybody know of inventive methods,
开始翻阅他的互联网历史记录。她发现，就在那个月早些时候，即7月1日，Mark在一个专门讨论自杀的论坛上发了帖。他使用网名“spooky”问道：“有人知道上吊方法的细节吗？就是那种有高处可以系绳子的地方？我读到过有人在监狱里自杀。有人知道什么创新的方法吗，
the ones you don't get to read in the road. the paper. A user going by the name Lee Dow had replied to Mark with the directive, check your email. That same day, Lee Dow sent through a long email with the detailed and explicit instructions that answered Mark's question. It closed with the words. If you have any questions, please email me. I'll get back to you ASAP. Good luck. Almost third. Almost three Three weeks later, Lee Dow sent Mark several more emails. They included words of encouragement, more information on hanging, and the repeated refrain that as a nurse, Lee Dow had seen many suicide attempts that didn't work,
那种你在报纸上读不到的方法。”一个叫Lee Dow的用户回复了Mark，指令是：“检查你的电子邮件。”当天，Lee Dow发来了一封长邮件，里面有详细且明确的说明，回答了Mark的问题。邮件结尾写道：“如果你有任何问题，请给我发邮件。我会尽快回复你。祝你好运。”大约三周后，Lee Dow又给Mark发了几封邮件。其中包括鼓励的话语、更多关于上吊的信息，以及反复强调作为一名护士，Lee Dow见过许多不成功的自杀尝试，
and therefore recommended hanging every time. In one email, Lee Dow detailed how two weeks earlier, another man in England had asked her to witness his suicide via webcam, so he wouldn't be alone when he would be alone when he was. died. Quote, In the end, I watched him go, and it was very peaceful, and I was pretty pleased I could make this guy's last moment special for him. We are not alone, and I don't want you to think that either.
因此每次都推荐上吊。在一封邮件中，Lee Dow详细描述了就在两周前，另一名英国男子曾请求她通过网络摄像头见证他的自杀，这样他在死时就不会孤单。引用：“最后，我看着他走了，过程非常平静，我很高兴能让这个人的最后一刻对他来说变得特别。我们并不孤单，我也不希望你那样想。”
Mark had replied to Lee, sharing his personal story and explaining how his chronic fatigue was getting worse with time. He described how he had practiced taking his own life, but he had. but hadn't been ready to do so yet. On July 23, Mark sent Lee an email that read in part. I keep holding on to the hope that things might change. If you want someone who's suicidal, I'm just not there yet. Four days later, Mark took his own life using the precise and specific method Lee Dow had sent him.
Mark回复了Lee，分享了他的个人故事，并解释了他的慢性疲劳是如何随着时间的推移而恶化的。他描述了自己曾练习过如何结束生命，但还没有准备好这样做。7月23日，Mark给Lee发了一封邮件，部分内容写道：“我一直抱着希望，事情可能会改变。如果你想要一个想自杀的人，我还没到那一步。”四天后，Mark使用Lee Dow发给他的精确而具体的方法结束了自己的生命。
A short time after he died, a final life. email landed in his inbox from Lee Dow. All it said was, Are you all right, Mark? Mark's mother Elaine was devastated by Carol's discoveries. To her, it was as though Lee Dow had decided to become a self-appointed executioner for Elaine's beloved son. Every time Mark went online, Lee Dow seemed to be whispering in his ear and appealing to his lowest thoughts. Mark's family handed over this evidence to local law enforcement. While the contact from Lee Dow was included in a coronial inquest into Mark's death, the inquest ultimately found that the cause of death was suicide and didn't recommend criminal
在他去世后不久，一封来自Lee Dow的最后邮件落入了他的收件箱。上面只写着：“你还好吗，Mark？”Mark的母亲Elaine对Carol的发现感到崩溃。对她来说，就好像Lee Dow决定成为Elaine心爱的儿子的自封行刑者。每次Mark上网，Lee Dow似乎都在他耳边低语，并诱导他最消极的想法。Mark的家人将这些证据交给了当地执法部门。虽然Lee Dow的联系记录被包含在对Mark死亡的死因调查中，但调查最终认定死因是自杀，并没有建议对任何人提出刑事
charges against anyone. A few weeks after Mark's death, Elaine Drybrough attempted to alert officials to her son's story, contacting authorities both at home in the UK and in the United States. She penned a letter in which she shared what she knew about the person who'd contacted Mark, that they went by the name Lee, had detailed medical knowledge about suicide, and supposedly lived in Minnesota. She was concerned that the individual might be getting some sort of pleasure from assisting and attending the death of other people.
指控。在Mark去世几周后，Elaine Drybrough试图向官员通报她儿子的故事，联系了英国和美国的当局。她写了一封信，分享了她所知道的关于联系Mark的那个人的一切：他们使用Lee这个名字，拥有关于自杀的详细医学知识，并且据称住在明尼苏达州。她担心此人可能从协助和参与他人的死亡中获得某种快感。
But Elaine's multiple attempts to raise the alarm went unanswered. When William Melchard Dinkle was interviewed by Minnesota investigators three and a half years later, he couldn't remember Mark a driver's name. But, after police provided him with Mark's email address, he recalled that it was connected to a 32-year-old Englishman who took his own life by hanging. Not long after Mark's death, Melchard Dinkle had come across an English newspaper article about the suicide that noted Mark had received assistance from someone in the United States
但Elaine多次拉响警报的尝试都石沉大海。三年半后，当William Melchert-Dinkel接受明尼苏达州调查人员采访时，他已经记不起Mark Drybrough的名字了。但是，在警方提供给Mark的电子邮件地址后，他回忆起这与一名32岁的英国人有关，那个人通过上吊结束了自己的生命。在Mark去世后不久，Melchert-Dinkel偶然看到了一篇关于这起自杀事件的英国报纸文章，文章指出Mark曾得到过一名美国人的协助，
who used the handle Lee Dow. This article had confirmed to Melchard Dinkle that he had been involved in another person's death. In Minnesota, counselling and encouraging people to take their own lives was against the law. But no one in the United States had ever been criminally charged with assisting suicide via the internet. This wasn't a case.
该人使用的网名是Lee Dow。这篇文章向Melchert-Dinkel证实，他参与了另一个人的死亡。在明尼苏达州，劝说和鼓励他人自杀是违法的。但美国从未有人因通过互联网协助自杀而被刑事起诉。这不是一个
of somebody physically assisting suicides, but doing so through words on a screen. If investigators were intent on pursuing charges against Melchard Dinkle, it was going to be a hard case to prosecute. More than a year after, members of the Minnesota Task Force interviewed William Melchard Dinkle, he was formally charged with two counts of advising, encouraging, or assisting suicide. One charge was for Mark Drybrough and the other for Nellner. Roger Kajugi. The case went before a judge-only trial in March 2011. Melchard Dinkle's defense attorney said that while his client's behavior was sick and abhorrent, it wasn't a crime. He argued that Melchard Dinkle's words alone could not be enough to incite Mark and Naja to suicide,
有人身体上协助自杀的案件，而是通过屏幕上的文字进行的。如果调查人员执意要对Melchert-Dinkel提起诉讼，这将是一个很难起诉的案件。在明尼苏达州特别工作组的成员采访William Melchert-Dinkel一年多后，他被正式指控犯有两项建议、鼓励或协助自杀罪。一项指控是针对Mark Drybrough，另一项是针对Nadia Kajuji。案件于2011年3月进入法官审判阶段。Melchert-Dinkel的辩护律师表示，虽然他当事人的行为是病态和令人厌恶的，但这并不是犯罪。他辩称，Melchert-Dinkel的言论本身不足以煽动Mark和Nadia自杀，
and that both had their own mental health crises that were at the root of their deaths. The prosecution countered by pointing out that Melchard Dinkle had been intent on seeing his victims die and that laws are in place to protect vulnerable people from such predatory behaviour. Ultimately, the now 52-year-old Melchard Dinkle was convicted of both counts. Naja Kujiji's mother, Deborah Chivalia, said the conviction was, quote, A great relief. This verdict today substantiates my belief that the internet cannot be allowed to become a safe haven for criminals.
而且两人都有各自的心理健康危机，这是他们死亡的根源。检方反驳说，Melchert-Dinkel一心想看到他的受害者死亡，而且法律的存在是为了保护弱势群体免受这种掠夺性行为的伤害。最终，现年52岁的Melchert-Dinkel两项罪名均成立。Nadia Kajuji的母亲Deborah Chivalia说，这一判决是“一种巨大的解脱”。今天的判决证实了我的信念，即互联网不能被允许成为罪犯的安全避风港。
Mark Dreiber's mother, Elaine, agreed, saying that if Melchard Dinkle had been found not guilty, it would have sent the message that inciting people to suicide was fine. William Melchard Dinkle subsequently appealed his conviction and had it reversed, with Minnesota's Supreme Court ruling that merely advising or encouraging, suicide was protected under the United States First Amendment, which protects freedom of speech. In 2014, Melchard Dinkle faced a retrial on the charge of assisting suicides alone. He was found guilty of assisting Mark Dreibera who had followed his suicide instructions to the letter. As Naja Kajuji hadn't taken her life the way Melchard Dinkle instructed,
Mark Drybrough的母亲Elaine表示赞同，她说如果Melchert-Dinkel被判无罪，那将传达出一种信息，即煽动他人自杀是可以的。William Melchert-Dinkel随后对判决提出上诉并被推翻，明尼苏达州最高法院裁定，仅仅建议或鼓励自杀受到美国宪法第一修正案的保护，该修正案保护言论自由。2014年，Melchert-Dinkel因协助自杀罪再次受审。他被判协助Mark Drybrough罪名成立，后者完全按照他的自杀指示行事。由于Nadia Kajuji并没有按照Melchert-Dinkel指示的方式结束生命，
in her case, he was found guilty of attempting to assist. assist. William Melchard Dinkle was sentenced to three years in prison, which would be suspended if he served just under six months and abided by the terms of his probation for the following 10 years. In February of 2015, Maltzert Dinkle was released after serving his 178-day sentence. A number of myths persist about suicide. These include the belief that suicide can't be prevented, that people who talk about it are simply seeking attention, and that suicides are rarely impulsive. The truth is that many suicides occur as a result of impulsive decisions. People who die from suicide often tell at least one other person beforehand that they no longer
在她的案件中，他被判犯有协助未遂罪。William Melchert-Dinkel被判处三年监禁，如果他服刑不到六个月并遵守缓刑条款10年，刑期将可暂缓执行。2015年2月，Melchert-Dinkel在服完178天刑期后获释。关于自杀，存在许多误区。其中包括认为自杀无法预防、谈论自杀的人只是在寻求关注，以及自杀很少是冲动行为。事实是，许多自杀是冲动决定的结果。死于自杀的人通常会在事前至少告诉另一个人他们不再
wish to live, and suicide can be prevented by multiple interventions. In Mark Drybrer's case, he was expressing a reluctance to take his own. life in the days right before he died. Naja Kuji recorded videos of herself talking about how she might regain her desire to live if she could sleep and find some happiness. Both she and Mark were experiencing depression in part due to external circumstances and traumatic personal events. With the right help and guidance, they could have gone on to lead happier lives.
想活下去，而自杀可以通过多种干预措施来预防。在Mark Drybrough的案例中，他在去世前几天表达了不想结束自己生命的念头。Nadia Kajuji录制了视频，谈论如果她能睡个好觉并找到一些快乐，她可能会重新获得活下去的欲望。她和Mark都因为外部环境和创伤性个人事件而经历着抑郁。在正确的帮助和指导下，他们本可以继续过上更幸福的生活。
There are many factors that can be. place an individual at risk of suicide, including personal loss and trauma, and societal risk factors like unsafe media representations of suicide and stigma associated with mental illness. Community factors such as discrimination also play a role, leading to an increased number of suicides and attempts amongst members of the LGBTIQI community and others who suffer discrimination. Experts say it is best to seek help through official channels that hire mental health professionals, rather than online forums where just anyone can post. Organizations such as Lifeline offer support for individuals experiencing suicidal thoughts and emotional distress.
有许多因素会使个人处于自杀风险中，包括个人损失和创伤，以及不安全的媒体自杀报道和与精神疾病相关的污名化等社会风险因素。歧视等社区因素也起着作用，导致LGBTIQI群体和其他遭受歧视的人群中自杀和自杀未遂的人数增加。专家建议最好通过聘请心理健康专业人员的官方渠道寻求帮助，而不是在任何人都可以发帖的在线论坛上。Lifeline等组织为经历自杀念头和情绪困扰的个人提供支持。
They also provide resources, tools and techniques on a wide range of topics relating to mental health struggles and various life stresses. People who are worried about someone who has expressed suicidal ideation can also find advice and guidance through these organisations. Law enforcement officials and attorneys who prosecuted William Melchard Dinkel have said that he sought to exploit the pain of individuals at their lowest point, rather than offer any help or words of support. Because there are often no investigations into suicides, it is impossible to know how many people took their own lives due to Melchard Dinkle's actions.
他们还提供有关心理健康斗争和各种生活压力的广泛主题的资源、工具和技巧。担心那些表达过自杀意念的人也可以通过这些组织找到建议和指导。起诉William Melchert-Dinkel的执法官员和律师表示，他试图利用处于人生最低谷的个人的痛苦，而不是提供任何帮助或支持的话语。由于自杀案件通常没有调查，因此不可能知道有多少人因为Melchert-Dinkel的行为而结束了自己的生命。
He told police he believed that there were five. By Celia Bley's estimation, the number is easily more than a dozen, and maybe as high as in the hundreds. The earliest instance of Melchard Dinkle's crimes that Celia Bley was able to find took place in 2002. Melchard Dinkle had told a young student living in the UK which tablets to take for an overdose. She did so and landed in a week-long coma as a result, but went on to make a full recovery. In stark contrast to William Melchard Dinkle, Celia Blay has likely saved countless lives
他告诉警方他认为有五人。据Celia Blay估计，这个数字很容易超过一打，甚至可能高达数百人。Celia Blay能够找到的Melchert-Dinkel犯罪的最早实例发生在2002年。Melchert-Dinkel曾告诉一名住在英国的年轻学生服用哪些药片来过量服药。她照做了，结果陷入了长达一周的昏迷，但最终完全康复了。与William Melchert-Dinkel形成鲜明对比的是，Celia Blay可能挽救了无数人的生命，
by alerting others to the danger he posed and doggedly pursuing him until he was caught. Law enforcement officials and parents of Melchard Dinkle's known victims have expressed their gratitude at Celia's actions. Elaine Drybra, the mother of Mark Dreibera, told reporters, quote, If it were not for Celia, he would still be at it. How many people have died? Naja Kajuji's brother has attempted to create some good out of the tragic loss of his sister by becoming a suicide prevention activist.
通过提醒他人他构成的危险，并锲而不舍地追捕他，直到他被抓获。执法官员和Melchert-Dinkel已知受害者的父母对Celia的行为表示了感谢。Mark Drybrough的母亲Elaine告诉记者：“如果不是Celia，他还会继续这样做。有多少人已经死了？”Nadia Kajuji的兄弟试图通过成为一名自杀预防活动家，从失去姐姐的悲剧中创造出一些积极的东西。
He works with the suicide prevention organisation Your Life Counts. Nothing is going to bring my sister back, he told reporters during one interview. But if I can help another family, I think that I've done all I can. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他在一次采访中告诉记者：“没有什么能把我的姐姐带回来。但如果我能帮助另一个家庭，我想我已经尽我所能了。”本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。